[Música]
me encontraba
tirado en el suelo
tratando de incorporarme cuando me doy
cuenta de que no me puedo incorporar
era porque estaba resbalando en mi
propia sangre
eso fue un 20 de noviembre del 2017
cuando la bestia del huracán maría atacó
a mi isla
y la destruyó
para que tengan una idea y ponerlo en
contexto yo vivo en puerto rico- la isla
del encanto donde una isla de 100 x 35
que significa que en tres horas y media
poder recorrer la isla de lado a lado
y un huracán categoría cuatro a cinco
que nos embistió
lleva el viento a 256 kilómetros por
hora donde un lápiz se convierte en un
proyectil que te puede matar
cuando salí un momento para destapar
unos desagües que estaban inundando la
casa una ráfaga me levanto y me tiro
contra el suelo
abriendo me la cabeza
por gracia y por destino cuando pasa
todo el de este huracán
salgo con mi vecindad a ver qué pasa ya
ver qué estaba sucediendo y había una
enfermera allí que no conocía que era
uno de mis vecinos
dónde
ella me futuro en la cabeza en mi
marquesina de mi casa
las primeras semanas
fueron solo de despejar escombros y
sacar a los todos los desperdicios y
todos los desechos que nos tenían
atrapados a todos en nuestras
comunidades
para ver cómo estaba pasando lo que
estaba sucediendo en la isla y entonces
vamos a ir a la capital para establecer
el primer centro donde todo el mundo se
vayan a la capital vayan al centro yo
por dicha pude tener una capacitación de
tanatología cometiendo mentar a todos y
dije bueno no no soy ni médico ni nada
que pareja pero vamos a hacer
voluntarios cuando llegó ahí nos damos
cuenta de que ni el gobierno sabía qué
hacer los mismos médicos no sabían qué
hacer y todo el mundo y qué hacemos
porque la destrucción era tanta no había
forma de comunicarse imagínense sin
electricidad sin agua porque la semana
anterior
el huracán irma también había pasado y
nos había dejado ya sin electricidad y
estábamos ayudando a las islas pequeñas
que están a nuestro alrededor
y en ese primer refugio pues empezamos a
ayudar a los que están en las islas y
las refugiadas y a los que empezaron a
llegar de todos los pueblos
lo interesante que entonces luego llegan
las milicias para ayudarlos y lo primero
que hacen es destruir el refugio es
decir se tienen que ir ahora porque aquí
es que vamos a establecer el fuerte aquí
es que vamos a estar dirigiendo toda la
ayuda para que la gente venga y recuerdo
todas las discusiones con el general
temer es que aquí hay personas
comprometidas
aquí hay personas que dependen de la
conexión eléctrica para respirar hay
personas heridas como no los vamos a
trasladar a una cancha de baloncesto y
ahí no saben ningún problema vamos a la
cancha de baloncesto donde saben que es
que había aguas de electricidad
y recuerdo aquella madre conectando el
respirador de su hija a su auto
para poder darle la respiración que
necesitaba a su hija
le decía el general discutiendo con él
caballero aquí una electricidad aquí no
hay agua como esta gente va a subsistir
y no nos vamos a traer combustible vamos
a hacer este generador emprender y todo
perfecto
un charles y el director del centro me
dice mira lo que sucede es que este
generador no está electricidad para
poder prender las luces y demás pero
este otro es para mover el agua para
poder dar agua en este edificio así que
necesitamos encender ambos te llega el
general el explicó caballero usted
podría ver tener la mitad del
combustible en este generador y el la
otra grande
no son mis órdenes
mis órdenes son llenar el contenedor
número 345 y así si es caballero no
quiero más simplemente la mitad aquí en
la amígdala acá y así fuimos
enfrentándonos a esa burbuja burrocracia
como le llamamos
lugar tras lugar y vamos entonces a los
charters a los refugios
yo siendo nadie no pero pudiendo ayudar
a las personas de decir que estás
haciendo aquí como los organizamos donde
están poniendo la comida
lo interesante de esto es que luego de
ir visitando los diferentes refugios
vimos como las diferentes comunidades
estaban interactuando comunidad como las
comunidades las dichas que hacer las
niñas porque dice bueno no tiene
electricidad pues también pasa ese
problema
la batería tengo mi cargado en la
batería sí pero cuando pasa una semana
cuando pasan tres cuatro un mes dos
meses tres meses no sé de nada
y cuando íbamos a visitar siguiendo
visitando los diferentes resfríos
veríamos lo mismo
esa desorganización esa es esperanza así
pero vamos va a venir la ayuda no va
haber problema
pero qué vamos a hacer
cuándo
vamos
a los hospitales o sucedieron cosas
absurdas
absurda
porque veíamos que no había electricidad
pero los
doctores estaban operando haciendo
operaciones de corazón abiertos con la
linterna de su celular
compañías como tesla fue y dijo bueno
aquí voy y vamos a arreglar estos casos
perfectos no hay electricidad vamos
entonces a arreglar todo esto y el
gobierno o sea que va a poner
electricidad o sea que no vamos a
necesitar más combustible
el permiso y sólo fue un hospital el que
accedió a poner placas solares y ese es
el único hospital que el día de hoy no
hay interrupción eléctrica en todos los
demás hospitales se continúa teniendo
interrupción eléctrica
situaciones tan absurdas como cuando
íbamos a las escuelas entonces empezaron
a abrir sin electricidad pero para
llevar los niños decía bueno cómo vamos
a almorzar con los maestros no es que
está prohibido que los maestros como en
los comedores escolares
sí sí hay una reglamentación federal que
prohíbe que los maestros no pero cómo
pero usted sabe que sabe cocinar en su
casa digas si usted y su casa y arroz
entonces organizamos entre los maestros
para que se unieran para entonces poder
llevar la comida a esos comedores y no a
tocar la comida ofrecida
y que ellos mismos fueran entonces que
empezar a dar comida entre ellos mismos
para poder atender la sanidad y así con
los empleados públicos
y así con los diferentes refugios que
habían alrededor de la isla
la realidad
sucedieron cosas que
contarles sería muy triste y penoso
pero todas estas cosas
fueron también maravillosas porque hubo
gente que ayudó muchísimo y se despertó
ese sentido de entonces que yo voy a
hacer porque no puedo cambiar mi
realidad sino a electricidad todo el
mundo entonces es igual porque imagina
es el más rico como saca dinero del
banco si nueva electricidad como compras
combustibles si no hay electricidad como
te comunicas
qué hacer entonces
y yo que trabaja con tecnología
no tengo trabajo no voy a poder hacer
nada
pues
algo bien mágico
comienza a pasar en la necesidad
cuando de momento empieza a hacer estas
situaciones geniales
donde la gente empieza a recoger los
paneles solares que se destruyeron por
toda la isla y empieza a conectarlos con
automóviles viejos con los generadores
con una bicicleta
a cargar entonces la batería y todos los
puertorriqueños entonces nos convertimos
en
gentes que pudieron sabían electricista
el carpintero el todo ese tipo de
personas
más allá de hacer algo gigantesco
haciendo las cosas pequeñas llegando por
qué por qué
el gobierno ni la milicia no le va a
ayudar porque yo no están preparados
para la realidad yo no sabía ni cómo
hacerlo
recuerdo una anécdota bien interesante
donde nos reuníamos en la noche algunos
líderes entonces había un muchacho que
decía mañana mi fiesta de cumpleaños a
pesar de todo voy a celebrar ya yo le
digo oye qué te parece mejor si me
acompañas al refugio que mañana vamos a
dar unos medicamentos que pudimos
recibir
y el cumpleaños de mi fiesta ya que me
regaló de ir a hacer algo por alguien y
sabes que sabía que esa persona nos iba
a ir como todo porque salíamos a las 5
de la madrugada para entonces entrar al
ayer al centro de la isla a poder
entonces llegar a pueblos que todavía no
tenían comunicación porque no había
ninguna antena
y levantada todavía en el país
y él fue el primero que lleva a las 5 de
la mañana
y así pues fuimos al centro de la isla a
ver qué era lo que podíamos hacer y así
fue mucha gente de bien ayudarnos pero
también hubo lo que no llegamos
tiburones del caribe porque hoy del
caribe de estas fundaciones que fueron
no ayudar y vamos a hacer sándwiches
vamos a hacer esto para cobrar el dinero
y luego marcharse
entonces yo sea pero porque tenemos que
esperar que vengan de afuera a
enseñarnos cómo hacer un sandwich cómo
recoger la comida de los sitios que
están que no tienen refrigeración
porque las compañías de hielo se negaban
a abrir porque hay una reglamentación
que nos prohíbe hacer el dispendio de
hielo
si no es en un empaque apropiado pero no
hielo para beber una cocacola beber un
refresco no para ponerle insulina para
poner los medicamentos que son
necesarios para alguien que alguien
sobreviva pero no puedo aprender
la máquina para hacerlo
es algo tonto
así que
de momento pero toda esta gente y digo a
alves ser verdad es que mi vecino no es
mi comunidad mi vecino me patean y
vecindario
de comunidad es el maestro que no tenía
que almorzar
mi comunidad es el barrendero que
apuesta por que cuando pasan tres meses
pierde con la basura
me va a hacer daño a mí porque él es
parte de mi comunidad yo tenemos que
ayudar a resolver ese problema de la
basura ya en situaciones de horror de
terror y hace un huracán una bomba una
tormenta un terremoto
la gente llamada hacer un vídeo somos
nosotros somos nosotros mismos porque la
común unidad es la palabra real la
comunidad
somos todos somos tú somos yo
el maestro todos no importa quien sea
así que nuestra responsabilidad no la
del gobierno no de la de la milicia es
la de nosotros de decir bueno que ellos
se hacen vamos a ayudar
bueno muchas gracias que tengan linda
tarde
[Aplausos]